it's been a journey of more than 6 000
miles and still it isn't nearly over
ukrainians continue to arrive in mexico
a country for which they don't need a
visa and which they hope is a step
towards sanctuary
this sports complex is now home to 100
or so a playground outside
the rows of bunk beds inside and for
elena the fifth country in a month since
leaving ukraine
you feel safe you are not in ukraine but
your hearts your heart uh and your mind
all your thoughts it's about ukraine
because uh my relatives in kiev and it's
very stressful it's hard you don't know
where to go you don't know what
you what you're expecting in another
place you can't start your life again
i i don't know how to do that can you
feel hope or positive i mean is there
anything
that gives you hope every minute really
but when you open news
it's um
i i don't know it's it's every day it's
harder and harder it's worse worse worse
and i don't know
the appeal here in tijuana is obvious
that brown fence is the border on the
other side the united states it is the
promise of america that's attracted so
many ukrainians
over the past few weeks more than 20 000
ukrainians have passed into the us
through this border crossing but last
weekend the rules changed now they have
to go through a formal process it meant
the chance of reaching america here
disappeared overnight
in the shelter they still hoped they'd
be away but while we were there they
were called together for an announcement
[Music]
no one will be crossing the border in
tijuana
you can feel the disappointment after
everything now this
oxana with her twins
said she felt crushed
we're in shock she said we don't know
what we have to do now but there are
lots of people who have the same problem
it's hard
for her children she sees the positives
they feel good here because they don't
hear the sirens she said they're not
having to go to bed in their clothes
because they don't know what will happen
at night
the spirit of the children is what keeps
them going but they now face hundreds of
more miles of travel more uncertainty
and this place about to close for good
still they hope though because without
that they say
what else is there greg milam sky news
tijuana